judging women for a choice that they  will never personally have to face is  ludicrous and brandon seems like you  need a little enlightenment buddy so  let's [ __ ] go did you know that every  10 seconds a report of child abuse is  made and how do you think your stance of  forcing children into the world under  circumstances in which they are unwanted  affects that child i'll pause it here  what she's saying you hear this argument  from pro-abortion people a lot is some  children are not wanted which is why  their parents kill them so it's better  for the child to be killed than to be  unwanted so if that's true then you must  support a policy of killing kids in  orphanages by killing kids in the foster  care system because they're not wanted  by their parents they're not wanted by  their families that's why they're wards  of the state  no no child is actually totally unwanted  one we want them to live and they're  wanted by god it is  just for them to be able to live